I'm really suspicious right now because
Isabelle's parents say that they accept
me but never have I ran into somebody
that was religious that would say oh you
know Jesus loves you and you know if you
have God in your heart and all this blah
blah it's fine I accept you when one
thing gets taken care of why do we find
something else to worry about
why do we do that Gabe goes into a panic
after the best case scenario happens
Isabelle's parents ultimately accept him
with love after he comes out as trans to
them but he can't help but spiral
thinking that response is too good to be
true and that they're suddenly going to
change their minds it just has me like
all anxious because are they gonna
accept me and their family
of this as he all
he all courage to ask Isabelle's dad for
her hand in marriage
which according to Isabelle's mom might
not be the best thing to do right now
see
I agree let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia I just
want to take a moment before we get
started to remind you or for the newbies
out there to let you know how much I
appreciate you I don't think I can say
it enough I love reading your insightful
perspectives some of you are hilarious
very witty but I say all of that to say
thank you thank you for playing a part
in building this solid interactive fun
entertaining community that we have
you're the best all right a few updates
before we get into Gabe starting off
with Mahmoud and Nicole
some other
last week he threatened to divorce her
after they had a physical altercation in
public because as Nicole puts it Mahmoud
picks on her about every little thing
okay so I will wait for five minutes it
will not come with the furnace I don't
give up whatever you want to do just go
Mahmoud ended up leaving Nicole at the
hotel where they were arguing to go home
this episode picks up with my mood's
brother bringing him back to Nicole and
demanding he apologized to her for his
behavior
he gets so upset at me he said no matter
what happened or what she did how you do
that how you left your wife somewhere
now I know some of you have your
theories on why my mood behaves the way
he does
I can't speak on that
but his brother does reveal that
Nicole's basically the first woman my
moods ever dealt with
Islam movement the queen at home but man
would never had women
this is wrist girlfriend wrist wife
you never go out he just work stay home
you have no experience say hi to my wife
still die
just say hi to your wife say hi to your
wife
Mahmoud eventually tells Nicole sorry
for leaving her there I'm sorry about
that anyway
yeah and then she lets them know he
can't keep throwing around the d word
divorce and you cannot just say you want
a divorce every single second like using
your power to kind of like using a power
trip
how many times have you told me that
this week after a bit of back and forth
they ultimately wind up at dinner with
mahmoud's brother and his wife
who offer a fresh perspective see mamu's
brother's wife is Chinese so they know
all about finding balance when you come
from different cultures
don't worry I'm fresh to come to Egypt
I remember when Ahmed Fatma come to
Egypt to have like a biggest fight more
than I think we have sometimes they now
like doing well if you really use the
heart it right God will help you
so as of right now divorce does not look
like it's the Nicole in mahmoud's future
and here's more proof last week on
Instagram my mood wished Nicole a happy
40th birthday he called her the best
thing that ever happened to him said he
loves her more than anything and added
this message after some heart emojis
quote with age some people tend to lose
their charm but you become Charming
wiser and more fun to spend time with
more fun to spend time with maybe that
means they're arguing less
hopefully at some point this season we
can see more of their romantic
connection because all I've seen is
fights and bickering about clothes I
know you can't fit everything into a
two-hour show with other couples every
week but
can we see some love so this Union here
can make a little bit more sense
all right another quick update on Jen
and orishi I know I haven't talked about
them in a minute because
quite frankly I wasn't interested
but this week piqued my interest because
Jen seems to want this relationship to
work so bad with Rishi that she's
ignoring all the red flags and her gut
instincts so much that it hurts
what am I doing let's backtrack for a
sec Jen moved to India to marry Rishi
when she got there she found out that he
has not told his family that they are in
a romantic relationship in fact his
family is actively looking for a wife
for him damn Rishi promises Jin that
eventually he's going to tell his family
the truth which is that he already has a
fiance and it's her
as all of this is going on jyn finds out
that she doesn't have the right visa to
stay in India so she has to return to
the U.S well it's a sign but before she
heads back home Rishi proposes to her
again
which in my opinion just proves that he
didn't take the first one serious if
it's real why do you have to do it twice
[Music]
let me stop I don't know that man
fast forward it's three months later and
Jen is back in Oklahoma but now her visa
situation has been worked out and she's
preparing to return to India before she
goes though she video chats her
girlfriends and one of them drops a
bombshell
how would you even know if he's not
loyal to you
He's just never given me any reason to
think that he wasn't how about when I
reached out to Rishi and he was hitting
on me
do you remember how he talked about me
sending Rishi a message on social media
yes
he responded
yeah I I get that that's like weird
it's
it's to me there was nothing about those
messages that made me uncomfortable
I just then
he sent me a photo of him with his shirt
off
I'm sending it to you right now
I don't understand why her friend is
just now telling her this
wait when was this
this is right before you went to go see
him
I knew that you were gonna do what you
want to do so I didn't tell you okay I
get the logic because Jen is about to
hear this and still go back to India but
I still think she should have told her
you know I try to give you advice and
you don't take it
I'm telling you now hoping that'll need
to give you some clarity
but I just sent you the screenshot that
man sent a pic with his shirt off in a
towel he sent a thirst trap
to another woman in her DMS and he's
engaged
that plus not telling his family about
Jen just looks like he does not take her
seriously Rishi had told me that he had
been faithful during or two years apart
I just want to make sure like for the
record you've not hooked up with anybody
in the last two years
you haven't chat with people that
potentially
you could hook up with no I was like um
totally engaged myself into my work I
didn't have time to this kind of things
as I told you so you would tell me if
you had
I was not available for anyone wow
that's disrespectful lying to her face
like that he's definitely I can't say
that in my opinion more than likely he
stepped out on June earlier in the
episode one of rishi's lady friends who
I'm assuming they're strictly friends
said she felt badverging because she
always sees him with women yeah
same girl same back to the photo when I
see the shirtless photo that Rishi has
sent Randy are you freaking kidding me
dude I don't know why he would send that
attention it's very addictive I'm just
disgusted
I'm disgusted Jen keeps this news of
rishi's pick to herself because her
family is already doubtful but on the
way to the airport to go back to India
she tells her sister-in-law oh
absolutely naughty has a freaking towel
on he doesn't even have pants on he's
naked
other than a towel like you just got out
of the shower that's bull Jennifer
that's not okay you have to set firm
boundaries where that's concerned that's
not okay as Jen is telling her bye she
breaks down in tears what am I doing
[Music]
this will make you think that following
your heart is not always the best thing
to do but hey sometimes when it comes to
love if you ain't done yet you ain't
done
I love him I have to go back I can't
help it
what I mean by that is some of us don't
leave relationships until we are forced
to
shock it up to comfortability fear of
being alone lack of faith and a better
future not wanting to see your partner
with someone else
it could be a number of reasons to why
we stay in something until it hits rock
bottom but that does not always have to
be the case things do not have to go
terribly wrong before you choose to
leave
I've learned from experience if someone
is choosing to be Reckless with my heart
ah they're not worthy of it they don't
have the capacity to take care of it so
why would I be irresponsible and
continue to place it in their hands time
is precious all right moving on finally
I just came out to Isabel's parents and
I don't know what to think right now
let's get into Isabelle's parents
surprising reaction to Gabe revealing
his trans I'm so scared because our
relationship is growing and
I hope it doesn't change how you see me
now because I've had bad experiences
when people just took back all the love
they gave to me is
perspective
going into this conversation Gabe and
Isabelle were expecting Isabelle's Dad
to have a huge problem with this news
considering the fact that he's a
conservative religious person but he
actually did what the Bible says to do
with
trans
his response shocked Gabe who was
bracing for the worstations
perfect
is
father tells Gabe that he is welcomed in
his home and then he gets up and gives
Gabe this huge embrace
[Music]
from your assets
yeah they are very fortunate very is
ideas
[Music]
well while Isabelle was soaking in
gratitude
anxiety started to take root in Gabe's
mind the day after the big combo with
her parents Gabe goes to Isabelle and
reveals he's struggling to accept their
acceptance it seems too good to be true
foreign
except
ion
the anxiety Gabe is feeling right now is
totally understandable I'm not a
therapist but it makes sense after
dealing with rejection from people's
parents for years feeling love and
acceptance for once make some skeptical
and uncomfortable it's new never have I
ran into somebody that was religious
that would say oh you know Jesus loves
you and you know if you have God in your
heart and all this blah blah it's fine I
accept you his mind is probably
questioning are they doing this for the
cameras are they going to think about it
and change their minds what happened at
the end of the night when we went our
separate ways like are they researching
did they look at my social media how do
they feel about actually
seeing how I really am but this is my
thing
and I'm preaching to the choir because I
have to remind myself this at times as
well
if you are hoping and asking for better
experiences
you have to allow yourself to receive
the better when it comes and not allow
doubt based off fears from the past to
take away the joy and sweet taste of
victory in that moment Gabe can't
control if Isabel's parents change their
minds in the future it just has me like
all anxious because are they going to
accept me and their family
but he can Relish in the fact that he
had enough courage and respect for them
to tell them his truth
that's something to be proud of and to
celebrate
fear don't ruin my party
period
Isabel reassures Gabe that all is well
and she lets him know that she'll talk
to her mom to double check fast forward
Gabe takes Isabelle's kids out to make
pottery and he asks them if they are
okay with him marrying their mom and
with big smiles they both say yes
foreign
[Music]
checks in with her mom at home and gets
an update on how she and her dad are
feeling about the whole situation
is
Cornell
your respect okay
persona
um
[Music]
Isabel lets her mom know that Cheetos
gave a stable in the decisions he makes
he's mature and he's confident
and then she asked her mom how would she
feel if she and Gabe were to get married
see
um
well I'm not sure if Isabelle is going
to give Gabe that memo because next week
it looks like he's moving forward with
asking Isabelle's dad for her hand and
marriage I Love Isabel very much and I
honestly want to ask you right now if I
have your permission to marry her
OES
or
[Music]
uh personally I think it's too soon he
just moved to Colombia he just revealed
the news to her parents the last thing
you want to do is overwhelm someone to a
point where it's too much and they just
say no
baby steps that's just my opinion he
might get a yes
we'll see all right 90 day fans fam make
sure you stick with E.T because we are
covering it all I will see you next time
foreign